a civil war in ethiopia
has been fought in the shadows the
government's cut the phone lines
and the internet switched off but the
blackout
doesn't hold in neighboring sudan
and here in the borderlands a vicious
conflict
is revealed
there are no facilities in hamda yet
there's nowhere to sleep and there's not
much to eat
but tens of thousands of ethiopians have
risked their lives to come here
they are tigrayians from the state of
tigre
fleeing war and ethnic hatred
was it a difficult journey to come here
it was
it was so difficult because we are
hungry
we are we don't have any water
any food we don't have any
transportation
abaddon and his wife rachel walked for
10 days to get here
there is sunlight yeah it's hot
there was so difficult i don't know
they have suffered and experienced great
trauma
the refugees driven from their homes by
bombing and
shelling often separated from family
members
in the chaos gabriel
told me his son was shot by soldiers as
they made their escape
what's his name
he was 12 killed said his father
in a town called adibai
who is that many passed us pictures like
this man
now searching for his wife and three
children
i'm crazy i'm going crazy my mind is not
working
how can my brain work
i suppose you must feel quite helpless
right now my mind is completely muddled
i've looked
everywhere and i don't know what to do
a power struggle between the ethiopian
government
and the leaders of tigres state has
triggered this conflict
and it is fueling deep-rooted ethnic
tensions
i would come cup for me this in the head
[Music]
at the local clinic we met a tigrayan
who said his neighbors tried to kill him
by revealing his identity to fighters
from another ethnic group
they came with access they attacked me
then talked about whether they had
killed me one took a look and said
he's alive his friend said well finish
him off
dr ted ross de fara was given the job of
treating his wounds
and we watched his patients squirm in
agony
everyone found this difficult to witness
what do injuries like this
tell you about the conflict across the
border
hatred extreme hatred insanity
absolute insanity there is no
rationale there is no
real human reason to do things like that
to a brother the village of handayet
has turned into a transit zone and we
watched as refugees
boarded buses for a camp the sudanese
are still trying to build
[Music]
there are more than a thousand refugees
in this convoy who've been offered
sanctuary by a country
that cannot afford to care for them and
they'll be taken to a ramshackle spot
12 hours from here last used in the
1980s for the victims
of the ethiopian famine another crisis
is building on the borderlands of sudan
with the un preparing for the arrival of
200
000 people victims of a war
now tearing ethiopia apart
john sparks sky news in ham diet